this is the sound of myanmar's
resistance
[Music]
long live and sangsu chi they shout
[Applause]
[Music]
the banging of pans a tradition to drive
out the devil
[Music]
but in yangon it's the military they
want to see the back of
the generals who launched a coup and
sent pro-democracy supporters
into hiding we believe we have to fight
the dictatorship
this kind of total power grab has put us
in a more difficult situation
democracy has totally vanished
a day after the coup military trucks
patrolled the streets of many cities
no sign of widespread public uprising
yet
many like tant zin are still in shock
the democracy he fought for has gone
[Music]
while tightly guarded mps are expected
to be able to go
home there's still no sign of former de
facto leader
ang tsuchi but colleagues believe
she's well
[Music]
foreign it's not just politicians who've
been detained
it was dark when soldiers arrived at
pro-democracy activist
mia a's house cctv shows him being led
away
his family powerless to protect him
it's quite heartbreaking for him you
know accompanied by the
military personnel and he's got a little
bag with him and we don't know where
he's being taken or how long he will be
there so
um i'm trying to you know uh
focus on what the international
community do to help with the situation
inside the country
while some hope the outside world will
send
help military supporters are celebrating
[Music]
[Applause]
myanmar isn't just divided it's
shattered
it's fragile democracy dead
siobhan robbins sky news